sh
Tonight inshallah We are continuing our
journey our
M through the summary
of
Z authored by the esteemed and late
scholar of Islam
sham we began discussing last
week the issue
of and the day of J more
specifically so we entered into the
chapter which deals with the virtues of
the day of J
Friday we spoke about some of the
narrations that introduced to
us and this day is a very important day
in the
week not just in the year as we will get
to inshallah but every week this is a
type of Celebration that is a weekly
Affair before we get into that I'd like
to mention
something and it's good for us every
week you know as a Prelude to what we're
going to speak about to discuss a
particular issue or topic or to mention
an anecdote
of times past
Etc that we want to discuss the
difference between that which is
wise and that which is
permissible
right that which
is
and it's been said by the scholars
of
[Silence]
that
it's been said that true understanding
true wisdom and understanding of the
legislation of Allah subhanahu waala is
just is not to merely know what is right
from what is
wrong what is right from what is wrong
is pretty
clearcut but true F in the on the stage
of
life is that an individual who has been
given wisdom by Allah is able to
differentiate
between what is good and what is
better and to be able to differentiate
between what is bad and what is worse
this is true
F and there is an issue which is that
which
is that which is
permissible that which there is no sin
involved in
directly doesn't necessarily
mean that it is a wise thing to
do what does that mean a lot of people
can't make that
distinction what does it mean when you
say that not everything that is
permissible is necessarily
wise it could even be said that not
everything that is
preferable preferred in every
circumstance and every time and place
and is not necessarily as appropriate
for every time and
place and a very similar example for
this is something along the lines of
law and common sense
right so for example we have certain
laws if you're walking down the sidewalk
and there is some people on the sidewalk
or there's people walking by or whatever
it is
and these individuals are in
public and you are V videotaping them
for instance or take pictures of
them this may be this may be lawful you
may have not broken the law by doing
this let's say a a police officer is is
standing on the sidewalk and you
run up and you shove a a video camera in
his face or whatever it
is you may not have committed a crime
per se but is that behavior
necessarily productive is it something
which is of
wisdom
right likewise for
instance the bare minimum for a man to
wear in making
Salah or in public
is the knee to
the to the
naval and to make Salah the co the
shoulders have to be covered with
something this is the bare
minimum this is the bare minimum of what
a man must wear when he's in public or
especially if he's going to
pray but is it necessarily wise for a
person to go to the mid or go out in
public dress this with just a pair
of long pants or shorts from his navl to
his knees and then just go outside
and walk around this is permissible the
person hasn't committed any crime they
have not done anything Haram they have
not done anything sinful per se but is
that necessarily appropriate
the answer is no that's not
appropriate or let's
say you know instead of me wearing a
regular thob and a regular
hat I wear hat with feathers coming out
of it right and I wear a thob that is
leopard print
thob it's I haven't imitated any
disbelievers I haven't initated animals
I haven't worn anything that is
particular to other religions so it may
be permissible in itself and then I go
to the Masjid to lead Sal that but
is that
appropriate no that is not
appropriate right certain
behavior is permissible but it may not
be
appropriate right it may not be
wise such as for example a person who
is a person who is has a serious
position and they're walking around
and you know acting foolish and acting
immature Etc there are many examples the
point is is
that not necessarily everything that is
permissible is something that should be
done or something that is appropriate
and we will give
examples of this from the Quran and from
the
Sunnah but the most important thing that
we need to
understand is the statement of Allah
subhah we need to understand the
statement of Allah which is
in in which Allah subhanahu waala says
we document that which they do and the
their actions in one of the meanings of
this
verse and
so is not exist in a
vacuum it's going to have effects and
ripples and ripple out to the world
around
you and those effects may be positive or
negative if they are positive then you
will be rewarded for this and if they
are negative then you will be held to
account for
this this is why we hold people to
account for negligence this is why we
hold people to account Etc because these
actions or lack of actions do have
effects if a person is negligent
and you know is a
zookeeper and is negligent with the
locks on the lion's
cage they didn't open the cage for the
lion to get out and eat the
visitors or attack the
visitors The Zookeeper didn't intend
didn't even want this to happen but the
negligence of not keeping this animal
locked up
properly the effects of that negligence
is something that that person will be
held to account for likewise everything
that we
do right everything that we
do the things that we do they may
themselves be something
permissible but the effects that they
will have may be
negative and this is why the prophet s.
was said
whoever believes in Allah in the last
day then he is to speak with that which
is good or remain
silent he said subhanahu waala and tell
my servants to say that which is best
that which is superior
right so what does this
mean he didn't say
s. whoever the last day then let him
speak with that which is permissible or
speak with that which is truthful though
all of these things are prerequisites of
something being
good but it is a level higher than that
and that is that it has to be good or
remain
silent he said commenting on this
narration this narration is an
evidence that when a person goes to say
something they should first think about
what it is they are about to
say if they are positive that what they
are about to say is good and will have
positive effects then they may
speak if they are sure that what they
are going to say is bad or will have a
bad
effect
then they are to remain silent and if
they
are then they are to remain silent we
have only been given permission to speak
with that which we are certain is good
good in itself and will have good
effects and
so if we understand this
concept we will come to understand
that only one for something to be
permissible in Islam that is one part of
the equation it also has to be
appropriate and a person could say that
not everything that is appropriate not
everything that is permissible is
appropriate for every time and
place when we go to speak about certain
issues
certain issues maybe historical events
that happened amongst the companions or
issues that you know the the people
that are unlearned or not well versed in
the meanings of the Quran and
Sunnah should we go and unveil these
issues to them in public no of course
not just we wouldn't feed our
newborn
a piece of steak right because a
newborn it's good it tastes good it's
fine it's healthy it's Hal it's all of
that but it's not appropriate for a
child of that age this is something that
we in large understand but a lot of
times people to play games with
words because they want to do something
or don't want to do
it and so it's very important important
for us to understand that not everything
that is truthful or everything that is
necessarily
permissible is necessarily appropriate
for every time and place I think this is
something that most of us understand it
is pretty Common
Sense the prophet s.
wasam said to and now if we look at the
Kaa the way that it's built it's a it's
almost exactly a cube but actually it
was not supposed to be that shape the
original
CA which ibraim
and built was
actually it was rectangular in shape so
it was a rectangle and then it was
built up it wasn't exactly a
cube and so qur when they built this CA
on the original foundations of
ibraim they did not have
enough
money Halal money or money that is pure
because they their condition was we will
only put funds into the building or the
rebuilding of the Kaaba that is
definitely pure so no money earned
through RBA no money earned through
prostit no money that has been swindled
or stolen or the property of another
will be used toward rebuilding the Caba
well they didn't have enough of this
pure money to rebuild the Caba exactly
as ibraim had rebuilt it so they built
it as it is
today and then they placed
markings which is what is referred to
as which is that kind of Crescent
shaped area there in front of the
Kaa this was to Mark the original
foundations of
ibim and this is why we don't make only
around the KA we make around the KA
and because that's the original
Foundation well when the prophet s.
wasam returned to
Mecca in the conquest of
Mecca when he
returned and the
Kaa was now under his control and Mecca
was now as well under the control of the
Muslims people of Mecca had accepted
Islam
Etc he said to
he said had it not been that your people
referring to had it not been that
qur are new to
Islam and have just left a time of
ignorance I would have demolished the
Caba and rebuilt
it upon the original foundations of
ibraim and I would have put two doors
into it a door for people to enter and a
door from which people to
exit
right so he didn't do that why not why
didn't he do it this was obviously
permissible it was actually it was
encouraged to rebuild it as the way that
ibraim had originally constructed
it however the effects of this on qur
would be negative and this these ill
effects this negativity would outweigh
any benefit to be had or achieved
by these people had just accepted
Islam and the
Kaa they grew up they all came together
they all collectively
believed that the Kaa was the most
holiest of
SES and the most holiest of places and
buildings in the
world not even 50 some years or
actually about 60 years
earlier the elders amongst them still
remembered watching when Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
destroyed ABA and his army that came to
demolish the Kaa there were still people
amongst them who remembered this that
Allah subhanahu wa taala divinely
defended the
Kaa and so the the position and the
status that the Kaa held in the hearts
of these people was was something
that
was well deeply
rooted and
so they've been at war with the prophet
Sall alai wasallam for all of these
all of these
years and then suddenly as soon as they
accept Islam and the
prophet comes and conquers Mecca the
first thing he does is destroy the Caba
this will cause Mass confusion this will
cause people to
misunderstand they have not
learned exalting the prophet s. wasam
they have not learned the true position
of the Kaa and Islam etc
etc so whilst this is something lawful
was lawful for him something that he
wished he could do he ultimately did not
do that why
because this would be something that
would have negative
effects this is something that we need
to understand this doesn't happen in
obligation and
prohibition though
can but this is something
that occurs in differentiating between
that which is good and that which is
better that which is permissible and
that which is
appropriate
right and so if we understand this we
will start
to use common sense and understand
how to employ the principles and the
oblig and the statements of Allah
subhanahu waala and his Prophet Sall
alai in our
lives he
said the
great he said when you address the
people address them with that which they
understand don't go above their heads
don't speak to them of something that is
too foreign for them to understand at
that
time he
said would you desire meaning lest Allah
and his messenger be be
lied
right
he
[Silence]
said anytime you speak to people with
something they cannot understand they're
not ready to understand
yet then it will always the statement of
yours or this information will always
act as as a source of FNA for some of
these people that can't understand
it and so we make sure that
we we make sure that we teach people
properly that we behave properly with
that which is
appropriate and this is why Allah
subhanahu waala
said
tell my servants to do to say and do
that which is
best not only that which is good or that
which is permissible or that which is
acceptable but they must do that which
is best we choose that which is best in
any
situation so for example if I have
guests come over to my
house honoring my guest and entertaining
my
guest is something
that I am obligated to
do but as well during this time let's
say I pray during that time I pray we're
not talking about obligatory prayer
we're speaking about additional optional
prayer is it better for me
to spend the time
praying or is it better for me to tend
to my guests obviously it is the second
the
latter is it permissible to pray yes
sure am I harming anyone of course
not it appropriate in that time and
place for me to choose that no it is
that is
inappropriate
right so this is an issue that we need
to take into
consideration and we need to keep it
in the Forefront of our minds whenever
we do something especially when it comes
to interaction with people especially
when it comes to interaction with
people before we continue on the issue
of I also would to mention
something that came up during the
week and these are just issues that
we that may arise and
I may find that they are beneficial
or of consequence to The Listener
because these are common
issues one of the issues that came up
and was asked throughout last
week was a question came up on whether
or not it is
permissible to use a means of making a
decision such as flipping a coin
coin right flipping a
coin so for
example should I go to this restaurant
or that restaurant or should I go right
or should I go left or should I buy this
thing or not buy it so I'm going to flip
a coin is this something which is
permissible the answer is this is not
permissible and
this is a type
of
Islam as Allah subhanahu waala mentioned
that which we'll discuss
inallah this is something which is as
Allah describes a filth from the
handiwork of a shaan so stay clear of it
and avoid it completely in order that
you all may attain
success this is what Allah subhanahu wa
taala says in the Quran regarding
alamam is different than casting
lots there is a difference
between
Alam and
and what is the difference that that is
that what is more more known is the
difference
between so what is let's begin with
what
aream is a type of deciding
method that the people of jilah the
pagans of
jilah used to use in order to make
decisions usually it was arrows or it
can have other ways we don't care about
the exact way that it was done we care
about the spirit of it right in the time
of the Prophet s. wasam the way that the
Islam would work is they would have
three piece three sticks or three arrows
or three things right could even be
rocks or anything that have one one of
these arrows has written on
it do
it or do it as it is Allah's will or
something along those
lines and then one another would have do
not do it and the other and the third
would be blank right BL blank or it
would have you know something try
again or ask again
or now what about if it if we have
something that has four or five the
magic eight ball all of this is the same
I don't know if those are around anymore
when I was a kid something called the
magic eight ball which is a
big looks a pool eight Bowl right
but it has a little window on
it and this window has I don't know
there's some kind of liquid inside of it
and there's things
written on this object that's
inside right and so the idea was the
magic eightball you ask a question you
know should I do this and then you shake
it and you look into the window and it
will float to the top and give you yes
do it or don't do it
or probably not or preferably not to or
whatever right I don't remember exactly
what was set on there there was a number
maybe eight or 10 different
answers that this magic eightball would
have or would present you okay just
because in the time of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam it was three
doesn't mean if it's four it's
permissible or if it's two it's
permissible this is all
Superstition this is all
impermissible so continuing on when a
person at that time would wish to do
something
something should I marry this woman or
should I go traveling or should I marry
this man or should I whatever it is
right they would draw one of these
arrows or one of these rocks or one of
these pieces and they would look at
it and whatever it said they believe
that that was guided and inspired by
God right we have many examples of
this I mentioned one the magic aball
another is the tarot cards right people
who use tarot cards this is all a type
of and this is all a type of a type of
sh minor sh in
Islam flipping the coin is part of
Islam this is different than drawing
Lots drawing Lots is mentioned in the
Quran twice
and it's also mentioned in the Sunnah of
the Prophet s.
wasam what is drawing
Lots
or is when we
have right that all have an equal right
to
something and there is no determining
Factor except
drawing as we say in America or in
English drawing straws right drawing
casting
lots this
is this is in this case permissible
this is how we make these
decisions so in the Quran Allah
subhanahu waala mentions drawing Lots
twice he mentions it in the story of
Zakaria and inah Al Iman
and he mentions it as well in the story
of
yunus so he mentions with regards to
Zacharia when Mariam was born her mother
had vowed Mariam a servant in the
house of Allah subhanahu waala and so
zakar and the other
Scholars had all debated as to who
should be her caretaker or who should
sponsor
her and
so they use their
pens and some of the MU mentioned that
they said okay throw his pen into the
river or into a small stream or a creek
and whoever whomever's pen will
float Upstream then this is the
person who will get
to
sponsor and so all of them threw their
pens into the stream and zakaria's pen
was the one that flew upstream or
against the current this is called
casting
lots right it's also mentioned that
Yus was on a ship and
as Allah subhah
mentions that they drew Lots because as
some of the scholars of T mentioned they
were in some bad Waters and they had
to lose weight and some people had to
be forsaken as well and so they drew
Lots as to who should be basically
take one for the team and go
overboard and so they all Drew lots and
it would const constantly come up as
yunus but they didn't want to throw
eunus overboard they viewed him as being
far too important and so he jumped
overboard because he realized that no
matter how many times they did it his
would always come up and so he
understood it as something from Allah
subhah regardless of how it took place
this is called a this is
notam right another example
is when the prophet s. wasam would
travel he would take one of his wives
with him which one of his wives would he
take well they all have an equal right
to go and so he would draw lots have his
wives draw lots and whoever whoever
won in that drawing then this is the one
he would take with
him this is for as the scholars of
mention
this is a determining factor with
regards to div dividing people's
rights right two people come to make
aan or let's say in a Masid where
where there's no IM let's say people
are going to lead Salah who should lead
in Salah the most versed in Quran as the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam said if
they both know the the two candidates
know the Quran equally then the most
versed amongst them in the Sunnah if
they are both equal in that then the one
of them who made hij first if they are
equal in that then the eldest let's say
they are equal in all of that then we
would cast lots we would have them draw
straws because they both have equal
rights to that this is called casting
lots this is drawing
straws this is something which is
permissible however we do it if you
remember at our fundraising dinners
for the mosque Foundation we have a
raffle right a giveaway and so we
have everyone's name in a bucket or in a
something that'll mix them up and then
we choose random names this is
called this is
permissible this is actually
prophetic however there is a difference
between that and flipping a coin to make
your decisions this is part of
superstition this is something which is
impermissible in
Islam how is
that the decision should be made in two
ways when I'm making a decision for
myself I need to make that decision and
use two things number one I need to use
facts and knowledge to give the edge to
one of the two options or many options
right weigh the factors and that to do
with that I am to ask those who are
well-versed and knowledgeable in that
field what I should do second of all I
am to
make is a gift from Allah subhanahu wa
taala that we were given in order to
make our decisions and it took the place
of in the time of
J and so if I am going to make a
decision you know let's get which
product am I going to buy let's say am I
going to buy well I try to look at
things objectively first
off and so I do my research on both
options or however many options there
are and I consult people in that field
so that I can get as much proper
information on the subject as I
can after this I will
make if I am still torn I will
make and then I will go with one of the
two there is a a kind
of myth that's going around where if you
make you should wait to have a dream
about it and do what the dream says that
is not correct the you
know there may come a dream associated
with that issue that may happen but that
is not a prerequisite that's not
necessarily the deciding factor of a
when a person makes a he goes with what
he feels is best if he made properly or
she and so this is different than Al is
is when everything is exactly equal
between
people and now we draw Lots in order to
or a raffle or whatever and I'll give an
example of
this when we have
let's say you know even though I I
don't to use this as an example
that much but in football American
football we have the coin toss at the
beginning of the game to decide who
going to get the ball first right that
coin toss flipping the
coin that it's the same action flipping
the coin to see which team gets the ball
first or flipping the coin to decide
which product I'm going to buy it's the
same action but in the case coin for the
football teams that is permissible that
is correct use of and in the other case
this is something which is Haram and
prohibited takes the place of
that and so these are things that I know
people may think well what you know
what's what's the big issue about just
flipping a coin or what's the big issue
we are not in a position
to make something big or small it is
Allah subhanahu wa taala who gives
things their
worth and their seriousness and their
gravity
right in the time of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam some people spread
some rumors
about what were the ramifications of
those rumors we're still talking about
them for 1500 years that's how serious
these it was about five people that's
how serious these five or seven or eight
people the rumors that they made and a
lot of these rumors weren't straight out
outright accusations they were just kind
of question marks you know I saw
this and I saw that wonder what's going
on
there and yet the ramifications are thus
far 1,500 years
later and the ramifications were that
Allah subhah
spoke about the issue and sent a
messenger
sent to the
prophet and it became part of our part
of our Quran and and right so the
ramifications were very serious but when
people were doing it at the time they
didn't think it was such a big deal it's
just a little rumor right but Allah
subhanahu waala says in rebuttal to this
mental ality he
said you all do this you say these
things all the while believing that they
are not so serious things that are to be
taken lightly yet with Allah and Allah's
estimate these things are very heinous
and
serious so the gauge of this is petty
and this is worthy this is of great
gravity and this is of little
significance that doesn't come from us
and what we immediately see here in
front of us this comes from Allah
subhanahu wa
taala this is enough for this
evening inshallah we will continue next
week in the book of
Al we spoke very little about Z
tonight but these are very two important
topics that to share with the
listeners